Now that we have seen how all the tools work individually, let's take a look at using them
all together. What we're going to try to do in this part of our tutorial is take the lake,
river and ocean tools and set up something that looks like this, where we have a lake that leads
into a river that leads into the ocean. So this is going to be pretty easy for us to set up. So
let's go over to the editor now. So this is just a level that we have created before. Remember,
it's got a landscape in it. And first thing we're going to want to add here is our ocean.
So we're going to put in our ocean. And then what I'm actually going to do is I'm going to come over
here and zero out the x, y and z location of our ocean just so that we have something that looks
like that. Alright, then what I'm going to do is I'm going to come in here, I'm going to look for
our lake. I'm going to add our water body lake. And I'm going to position our lake so that it sits on
top of the little bit of a surface that is created from our ocean. And then last but not least, I'm
going to put in a river. And then we're going to need to take this river and actually drag it down
and then move it over. There we go. We could move it this way. And the other thing we're going to
need to move these splines over so that they kind of intersect with our river. Whoa, that was a
little bit too far over. So let me hit Ctrl Z to undo that. We're going to do something like this.
And one of the other things that you are going to want to make sure, notice that we don't get this
really great transition between the river and the lake here because they're at different heights.
So what we want to do is we want to make sure our water body lake here is at 280. And then we're
going to grab our river here and we're going to say 280. And that way we have them both on the same
the same level so that they are not giving us that really weird looking transitional piece. So
here, don't forget our river is also flowing backwards. So we can change this just by going
negative 128. And that is going to push this going the other direction. So here again, we can do
negative 128. And then here right here, we can also do negative 128. And that's going to push our
river down. So let's hold Alt and just kind of drag some of these down here. And we're going to
have to kind of make start making stuff go down a little bit. So remember nice, even nice easy, I
should say ways to get down and we'll eventually make it down to the water all the way down here.
So we can fix some of this with some adjustments afterwards. So get the
water coming down here. Now one of the interesting things that we would want to do here,
if we grab our last point here, and we take this actually this is our last point here, we take this,
we're going to set this to zero. And if we set this one to zero as well, we'll get a really nice
transition between what is kind of coming down the hill and what is going into the water. So
you know, this is just going to take a little bit of work here to kind of make things look more
like a river, pulling things down, pushing things back up. Maybe we add some more spline points to
give us a little bit more elevation to work with. And this is really how we're going to make our
thing look like a river. Don't forget, we can also come in here and change this to say 1024,
you know, make things a little bit more narrow and easier to work with. We can grab both of these
ones and hit them to 1024 just to make things a little bit more narrow. And we'll select all of
these just by holding down control and set them all to 1024. There we go. Look at that. That just
gives us a lot easier, more narrow narrowly defined river to work with. So there we go. We got all
that. So that is coming down into the ocean right there. So that's looking pretty good. Maybe add
a little spline point there. Bring it down a little bit, bring this one down. You know, it's just a
little bit of finessing. Look, we've got a little bit going outside over here. So we might just want
to bring this over. Maybe we adjust the point like that and bring that over. Maybe we add a new
spline here so we can do something like this. So and then we have the also remember that we have
the ability to come here and do things like we add a little bit of maybe curl noise. There we go.
Mess up the rivers of values a little bit. Do the same thing for our lake here. So we're going to
go up and we're going to look for our our terrain here and water height map settings effects. And
we're going to go to our curl noise. Do like a point two. There we go. We like a point one, two,
five. We get some interesting results here. We might want to do this for our overall water itself.
So we're going to go to our water body ocean. Remember, we come down here to our point two.
There we go. And point one, two, five. So we get some cool looking results. And that is basically
using them all together. So what I want everybody to do is just take a little bit of time before
moving on to the next portion in this tutorial and just mess around with the different settings here
and kind of moving things around trying to get your landscape to match the river's surface.
Don't be afraid to also come up here into your landscape and try and use some of the the landscape
tools, maybe smooth things out. You know, we can also add another layer here. So we will just do
edit layers and hit select. And then we can do all types of stuff we can sculpt up, or we can sculpt
down. There's a lot of things that we can do here to try to finesse the landscape to make it so that
it will fit this river a little bit better. So you know, just spend some time now trying to do that.
We can you know, there's just all types of really cool stuff we can do. We can run some erosion on
these hills and give them like a really cool looking weathered look. So again, a lot of stuff that we
can do here to get us to have something that's similar to this. So again, spend the next five to
10 minutes just messing around with the various settings and seeing what you can create and seeing
how simple it is to use these tools to make something that can fit whatever your needs are for rivers,
lakes or oceans.